this is theta cos Matthews I'm the guy
that you're talking about all around the
country as the cussing pastor yes I
curse hell Jesus probably curse Jesus be
setting up never looking at you
ignorance Negroes as in damn I made that
fool you got to be careful ladies who
you you can some of anything and
everybody do you kiss your flock with
that mouth that guy's spin the holy
ass daddy it's the cussing pastor and
the only thing he has in common with
Billy Graham is that they're both a
little ashy
dropping f-bombs in the name of religion
is better than dropping actual bombs
because of religion woked joke as long
as he's not giving reach-arounds to
altar boys I don't give a what he
says oh damn cuss words are a gift from
God
without them all rappers would be Will
Smith Bill Cosby famously refused to use
profanity but he'll be cursing up a
storm in prison when he's forced to take
his summit pudding sleep Rooney
I heard George Carlin used to do a bit
about the seven dirty words you can't
say on television let's see how it holds
up piss sucker mother tits
turns out it's now four that's progress
I wouldn't mind adding squirt to the
list that was gross squirt
Thaddius has a clean soul attached to a
filthy mouth but you got to preach blue
to put asses in the pew that's why I
flew the custom pastor to Hollywood
where everyone's Jewish for this week's
ce-web-rity profile there's all this
faster Mathews
you're the first to arrive have a seat
thank you so much for speaking at my
super secret celebrity prayer group now
thanks to the godless liberals who run
Hollywood the most hated group here
isn't women or people of color it's
Christians well I don't consider myself
a Christian I call myself a spiritualist
and I think that everyone even if as
these characters in Hollywood should be
able to address themselves to the God of
their choice unless it's the Church of
Scientology then damn them to hell I say
Oh they've all the time
is it the cursing pastor or the cussing
path it's the cussing pastor there's a
difference okay in cussing I use words
that you may think are not the proper
words I don't mind with all of them for
the record okay if I tell you take yours
to hell you going to hell you ain't no
damn good uh-huh you know you some other
lowlife that's cursing I was like three
examples there was a lot but Jesus was a
custom do you think Jesus customized my
name we're hammer in the nails into his
hands if somebody been putting the nails
in your hand you said a little to
with you I definitely would
did your message tailored to more the
black community are you open to all the
truth is not telling made the truth is
just the truth no matter who you are no
crime Jesus was not a white man I know
that blond hair blue eyes guy who you
know blond hair blue eyes nice abs you
know his name is seizure Borgy oh Jesus
his name was senior boy Geo he was the
homosexual Jesus was a homosexual that
one y'all got on the wall oh the one
that we have
yes he looks like a homosexual are you a
Steelers fan yes I am
what do you think was that a catch we
should win to the Super Bowl I know I
had all my money on the Super Bowl and I
thought the stills worst real thing okay
either the Bible was against gambling I
think that one of the things that the
church has done your elegan aiding young
folk because you've got all of these
doctrines and these misconceptions of
what Jesus said and he'll you and now
it's about being real it's about the
truth and I don't give a damn what you
bitches say and no you who is you were
put in facebook prison I just got on
Facebook jail Friday I went back in
while I was here and that is
statistically most people to get out of
facebook jail end up back in facebook
jail church is boring not mine that's
what I'm saying you've made something
that a lot of young people find boring
very entertaining and I don't get paid
at my church I get no salary you don't
pass we pass the basket of course okay
because church is a business but you'll
have to pay taxes praise the Lord
what about premarital sex what about it
is it okay I wouldn't have a woman the
lane try that I would uh-huh would you
know I might need to try it out for a
year year and a half oh no what you
riding in cuz I like a lot of know
freaky things okay so you may not be
known free so yeah it's a turn-on to me
to watch a woman take a dildo and do
that thing to a I'll get that thing that
swirls all around hell when you get 60
years old there is less work for you oh
no no I'm listen I'm all for taking a
shortcut wherever I can
I didn't mean to imply that I don't need
hell let me tell you something some of
the biggest freaks I've ever found is in
the church
you get one limb I never did this a
fault in my life
then she blow your like your trombone I
have a masseuse if you if you needed an
expedient how do you justify swearing
when Ephesians chapter 4 verse 29 says
do not let any unwholesome talk come out
of your mouth but only what is helpful
for building others up what's
unwholesome to you does it have to be
unwholesome for me yes why because all
men are created equal
No
we're not okay I don't think that the
problem that's in you want massage no
that's alright you sure you got a sister
you got to have a man rub because it's
stronger feels way better I know some
strong women that can do it good you
don't mind your male pastor taking up
the ansan dick you don't mind when he
lays hands on your own Sunday morning
his hands has been on some man's sweaty
balls is it really possible to pray the
gay away if you like a little not all
gay people have anal sex they don't know
what do they do
blowjobs that's all handed yeah and just
like a lot of straight men like anal sex
some freaking you some straight men like
a finger in there but from there lady
your butthole doesn't know the
difference between a big finger and a
small dick I better go
no wait no wait doesn't know it doesn't
what's your favorite cut sport
see it's so descriptive you
give me a white a black
I don't ever put a color
and probably watching sweaty mother yes
so many mothers any Christian worth his
salt watches Fox News so I trust you've
seen ads for the wonder Bible no it's
this plastic little radio and then it
just reads you some out of context
scripture with no real message the only
thing I wonder is how they haven't gone
bankrupt but I say we take that 1987
technology and create a product that
even non-believers would find coolest
I could create one of those throw
away your wonder Bible it's the boom
Bible by Thaddeus the good book just got
better
paper Bibles are so flimsy and
old-fashioned knows
with the boom Bible the sacred
scriptures are available at the touch of
a button the Lord is my shepherd I shall
not want bar mother can thank the king
Kendrick version of the scriptures that
is written and read by the cussing
pastor himself
Thaddeus Matthews a raw street-smart
remix of the Holy Word
take God's ghettoblaster with you
everywhere you go
you can you can finger you can suck on
them titties but if you God's gonna take
your head down
worldstar you've gotta reach the kids to
teach the kids take the evil out the
people there be acting right cause both
black and white is smoking crack tonight
take it on faith there's nothing cooler
other pieces of do do fit damn when
you don't know what to say let God and
Thaddeus speak for you
I see pew late with pigs and now I'm
don't you know the boon Bible by
Thaddeus keep your favorite filthy
pastor right at your fingertips and I
swear to God act now and will include
close to a pound and a half of skirt
steak and this coffee mug that says boss
bitch called today
so much more talk about dildos and I was
expecting from a pastor